as news of the covet 19 pandemic shook
the world dr ann wiley's career had
primarily focused on testing for the
presence of bacteria using saliva
samples
faced with an urgent need for easy and
affordable testing wiley joined a group
of scientists at yale school of public
health and began to investigate saliva
as a viable sample type for sars cov2
detection
her recent publications include
saliva or nasopharyngeal suave specimens
for detection of stars kovi 2 and saliva
as a gold standard sample for sars kovi
2 detection
in 2021 she was awarded the kobit 19
research award from the yale school of
public health
we are truly pleased to have you with us
dr anne wiley
thank you anne
okay great
so let's start today with talking about
how you became interested in salivary
diagnostics
thanks susan for that lovely
introduction and to the researcher for
supporting this important dialogue about
saliva as a solution for diagnostics
particularly for sars kobe 2 detection
i actually started working with saliva
as a sample type during my phd program
at utrecht in the netherlands we're
investigating streptococcus pneumoniae
pneumococcus as it's also known is quite
commonly found in our upper respiratory
tracts it's been present in humans for
centuries though benign for most people
most of the time pneumococcus can cause
diseases such as pneumonia and other
respiratory tract infections
my research goal was to better
understand its true prevalence in the
community and what that meant in regards
to both disease progression and
vaccination strategies
along the way we learned that in the
early 1900s saliva was the sample choice
for studying pneumococcus so we thought
why not give it a go
thanks to my local school and later some
older adults in the community my phd
demonstrated that compared to the gold
standard nesopharyngeal swab saliva is
sensitive as a sample type for the
detection of pneumococcus and healthy
individuals
importantly while saliva performed well
for participants of all ages in my
research saliva worked even better in
older adults a particularly vulnerable
population to respiratory infectious
diseases
so your early research involved a
revival of saliva saliva testing for the
detection of a potential potentially
lethal respiratory pathogen in a broad
community based population i'm seeing a
parallel to the stars kobe 2.
it's indeed turned out that way but
entering the covert 19 pandemic however
i did not immediately expect a useful
saliva yet with hospitals around the
world relying on mesopharyngeal swabs
with all the global supply chains
collapse we heard healthcare workers
worrying about constant exposure to this
new virus every day all day they're
collecting these differential swabs
risking being sneezed and coughed on and
sometimes without the proper ppe to
protect them
at the same time patients became
increasingly hesitant to get tested due
to the discomfort they experienced from
nasopharyngeal sobbing with all this i
couldn't help but wonder if saliva could
be a viable testing solution for sales
kobe 2.
absolutely np suavene was the only mass
parts kobe 2 test available worldwide we
needed more options to fully address
pandemic scale testing demands
so as you began researching saliva for
stars kobe 2 in the early 2020 time
period what obstacles did you face
so the biggest obstacle in 2020 um well
although my previous research testing
hundreds of samples had allowed me to
perfect the use of saliva as a sample in
2020 most labs around the country
neither had the same experience nor the
skill set that comes from a nearly a
decade of r d on saliva
and doesn't mean that lab techs didn't
necessarily have the go-to methods or
protocols in place to effectively and
reliably process saliva whereas my
research had taught me a good number of
tricks
in particular i'd already tested my
process with many different reagents and
found some that worked particularly well
reagents from thermo fisher actually
so early challenges were yeah
so early challenges were refining what i
already knew about saliva for pandemic
conditions but the biggest and the most
important challenge was demonstrating
that saliva as a sample holds so much
potential for fast cov2 testing
so for well over a year now i've been
working to highlight how the methods the
protocol the combination of reagents and
pcr technology are all important for
ensuring a sensitive and reliable saliva
test that's a big part of what the
saliva direct team is focused on doing
now
you know at thermal fissure our mission
is to make the world healthier cleaner
and safer
knowing thermal fissure agents maximize
the saliva direct protocol is great news
for our listeners
what specifically makes saliva well
suited for monitoring infectious
diseases
well saliva is actually already well
established for other health measures
it's well suited for also monitoring
infectious diseases for three main
reasons
first it's incredibly easy to collect
saliva from subjects it doesn't require
high-level healthcare workers to take
samples and they've been incredibly
stretched then as we know
importantly saliva can be reliably
self-collected by pretty much anyone
this supports at-home collection and
helps protect our healthcare workers
from exposure and burnout
second webisite we've designed the
saliva direct assay to decrease resource
utilization and increase throughput
which is so important for overburdened
labs during pandemic conditions
experienced labs using saliva direct
reliably produce pcr results within a
few hours
third we've shown that for sas kobe 2
you don't need expensive tubes or
buffers or special equipment and you
don't need cold chain transport so all
together these attributes make saliva
based tests much less costly than other
approaches
and if you're wanting to monitor disease
nationally you need to have sustainable
reliable low-cost solutions and ones
that are not burdensome to the public
using saliva as a sample was cyberdirect
for example can also yield major public
health benefits globally especially in
low resource settings
so you're saying that saliva as a sample
for sars kovi test starts ov2 testing
reduces collection burdens on health
care providers
improves the patient compliance
speeds the lab throughput lowers overall
costs and more importantly detects
infections at earlier asymptomatic
stages that means public and private
health care systems potentially could
better detect outbreaks prevent
transmission and stretch budgets for
stars cove test stars cov2 testing by
including saliva as a sample in their
testing portfolio
exactly and public health systems around
the world are just beginning to
actualize these types of results
wow very very fascinating exciting too
diverging now to twitter you've
referenced being called the spit queen
of yale
tell us what can saliva do that nasal
swabs can't
thanks susan i certainly didn't expect
bitcoin to gain such traction with the
media and in truth the title is
unexpectedly bestowed upon me in a
meeting by the dean of the yale school
of medicine nancy brown
but honestly as a sample type saliva is
more democratic than imperial and to
your question because saliva is so easy
to collect it can actually increase
testing compliance as you noted while
preserving pcr quality detection in many
cases as well as or better than nasal
swabs
there's research showing that many
individuals prefer giving saliva samples
than being swapped especially when
undergoing testing every week
interestingly and importantly a number
of studies have found that size kobe 2
can be detected earlier by saliva
samples as compared to nasal swabs
we also see that cs5 seems to clear
faster from saliva than from nasal swabs
we've all heard how swabs can test
pcr-positive for up to 90 days or even
longer post-start kobe 2 infection
we're just not really seeing this with
saliva and if you look at south kobe 2
detection in saliva and swabs over the
course of infection the virus signal
seems to be more please be cleared more
rapidly from saliva
this suggests that saliva could give a
better representation of the actual
clinical infection rather than remnant
rna still shedding later on
all of this is so compelling and
why is saliva not been more widely
accepted as a sample type
well fortunately saliva is gaining
acceptance daily but there is no obvious
answer to your question but what i can
tell you is decades ago saliva was
actually already widely accepted and
widely successful as a sample type in
infectious disease studies
during the antibiotic era research and
diagnostic practices shifted it's not
clear why saliva went out of fashion but
it lost its place as a traditional
sample type
then in the mid-1900s when i think we
started realizing that antibiotics
hadn't actually solved everything
infectious disease research was
reintroduced but for some reason using
nasopharyngeal swabs
maybe one reason nasopharyngeal swabs
took hold was that infants and children
experience less discomfort during the
collection process unlike adults where
it can cause real discomfort or even
burning sensations
we also know that many people react
strongly to swabs with sneezing and
coughing which is not ideal for
infectious infection control
the way i see it saliva as a sample
experienced a big generation gap what
were once standard practices for
properly processing saliva have just
fallen out of use
and modern processes for nasopharyngeal
swabs don't always work well for saliva
saliva requires sample specific handling
you wouldn't use a swab-based protocol
to process a blood sample for example
you need to account for the different
composition of blood samples and process
accordingly
in line with that if you received a
urine sample you choose a test
specifically designed for that
you simply shouldn't just take a method
that works for swabs apply it to saliva
and expect it to work they are different
sample types this is why many labs have
failed to get useful results from saliva
we do need to focus on the labs that
have found effective methods for
processing saliva for reliable sales
cov2 detection we should be focusing on
and further developing those successful
methods
what is the future of saliva beyond the
kobit pandemic
this is definitely just a start for
saliva the ease of sample collection and
how much cheaper it can be to do really
opens up options for more streamlined
testing paradigms i really see it's
great value in clinical research which
so often suffers from limited funds this
could really help make those funds go
further and help us learn even more
about how common infectious diseases
circulate within our communities
interesting
what are some of the challenges you see
for the future of saliva testing
currently the biggest challenge is
sourcing saliva samples positive for
other target diseases we may want to
detect
to do this you need to have the sample
which is considered the gold standard
for that disease together with a saliva
sample taken from the same patient at
the same time
there are currently so few cases of
other respiratory disease infections
circulating in our communities such as
influenza for example that while that is
of course great news for public health
for us in the lab it's been hard to get
these samples and further develop saliva
also through the pandemic we've seen
that saliva is being held up to much
greater scrutiny for validation
anterior nasal swabs the ones that go
only a little way up your nose if we
take those for example they were already
known in diagnostics to be less
sensitive than the gold standard
nasopharyngeal swab but somehow anterior
nasal swabs have been much more rapidly
accepted than saliva and we've actually
proven that certain saliva based tests
to be at least as sensitive as
nasopharyngeal swabs when used properly
what are kosh what are you cautious
about when it comes to using saliva as a
sample type
and what are you hopeful for about
saliva as a sample type
for the best part of your question i'm
cautious and concerned about
misinformation i'm stunned by the amount
of misinformed conclusions circulating
in the literature and the media
the culprits are hastily and poorly
designed studies either saliva is not
being collected properly or has not been
processed properly or the study
population is neither properly described
nor adequately controlled and in the
race to contain cobra 19 many reviewers
are not recognizing city flaws allowing
the publications of incomplete
conclusions which has led to an array of
discrepant findings
but on the other hand i'm also
optimistic i'm hopeful about the solid
work being accomplished in my lab at
yale of course as well as in many others
we need to share publish and implement
properly validated methods for saliva
testing worldwide the laboratory
community is passionate about patients
we've developed proven saliva-based
methods we've developed proven
saliva-based methods that detect sars
kobe 2 reliably without missing positive
cases
and what is currently inspiring your
research today
if you had unlimited resources what
would you do next
oh next
um i'm excited about just what else we
can learn when using saliva as a sample
type being so easy to collect we can use
saliva and research to better understand
what goes on in the community before
disease cases end up at the hospital
with unlimited research i definitely
expand our research in salivary
diagnostics for other infectious
diseases but also for preventative
health
we've seen how easy it is to set up
testing programs and how amenable people
are to give us a liver sample it would
be great if we could provide a way to
save people from having to travel to
clinics when they're ill or encouraging
more people to do more regular screening
i probably invest further in
implementation of saliva based testing
within our communities particularly for
underserved patient populations this
starts in the lab of course in a perfect
world all public health labs would have
a protocol in place allowing them to
scale up saliva based testing when
needed
also as a country we must be supportive
of the new public health habit of
frequent covert 19 testing
this will require public service
education campaigns and significant
community leadership so people
understand that even when vaccinated
they can still catch and potentially
transmit fast kobe 2.
a key component to resolving this and
future pandemics is testing either for
pathogen surveillance or for the rapid
ramp up of testing in response to
outbreaks and for this saliva is an
excellent solution
great to hear
thank you so much for your time today
thank you so much for having me
yeah i i actually was especially
appreciated hearing about the challenges
that inspired you and your team to so
quickly develop a way to use saliva as a
good alternative
to meet the enormous demands for cobit
19 testing over the the last 18 months
it's incredible that
working under the pressure in the midst
of a pandemic
the solution you and your team came up
with circumvented the the swab supply
chain challenges and simultaneously made
people and health care workers safer
while they were getting their kobit 19
tests done
thanks susan it's certainly been a
massive collaborative effort right
across the board between academic
industry
hospitals and i think it's just been so
inspiring to see what we've all been
able to achieve as you say like so
quickly when all working together and
really i'm really excited to see
what we can take from what we've learned
whether it's the development and
salivary diagnostics or even how
collaborative we can be to drive
innovation forward
exactly yeah i was thinking
um that saliva-based testing is going to
remain with us and it's also really
great to hear your optimism about the
future of salivary diagnostics
there there is yet work to be done
though right
yeah there definitely is but it's
certainly it's very exciting to know
about just you know how this can
transform potentially clinical
diagnostics going forward
truly and we look forward to following
the innovative solutions that come from
your research in the very near future
i'm just thankful
yeah thank you very much
yeah thank you for taking the time to
share your insights with us
no problem thank you for having me
so with that
we thank you all for joining us for this
podcast and close the session now